the stage is set
and this lot
are all asleep
guys the lines are up the lines are up
i'm bertie gregory
i'm a nacho explorer
and wildlife filmmaker
my team and i have been crossing the
planet let's do this to tell wildlife
stories in a rapidly changing world
coming back uh-oh
hi time to get out
but these incredible animal moments
they're only half the story
what it took to get there
that is terrifying the conditions
the odds let's go let's go that's
entirely its own adventure
look i'm trying to film penguins oh and
i've missed it
this isn't just a peak behind the scenes
oh that was quite close it's a journey
that sounded like a big crack
and you're invited we're going to the
toughest places in the world to film
straight off the mountain
this is the danger zone
wow look at that
whoa whoa tiger tiger
[Music]
the thing that makes me most excited is
if i have no idea what's in store for us
epic adventures with bertie gregory a
disney plus day premiere september 8th
on disney plus